when you hear the word quality what are
some specific things that come to mind
and whether that could be a particular
patient experience at a hospital
experience that you were at and that
helped you have a better better
articulate your own thoughts on what
quality is quality is behind everything
if we take now health infrastructure I
have that experience of contracting
people to do the hospital and they build
it in the wrong way and imagine that it
delayed the the work of health
professional for six months we delayed
six months how many deaths are we going
to have because health professional
whether a were not able to be scare
that's one now the money we lose because
we have to destroy and rebuild and the
time we lose it sits behind everything
all the chain of service and all the
tools we need to give to have to give
the proper service behind all this
starting with education continue with
the the the quality the behavior you
have this is also something that is very
important all along that chain from
infrastructure from the type of stuff
you have from the type of medicine you
use for the equipment you use to give
that meeting from the way you talk to
the patient and you you explain and
dialogue with the patient from the way
you you make the patient participate in
in whole health and from the way you
plan with the patient the way is going
to the same is going to pass through to
recover or at which extent it will
recover to make him participate in the
future handicap management you will have
all this need quality an issue ms one
point at you you will see the patient
will not contribute to is part four
owners will not own its own health or
will be will be harmed by what you are
doing or by what others are doing
so that's mean at all stage you need
people to to to enter in the in the job
to do the job to concrete the job with
quality